Hello and welcome to Project 1.5
of the iOS Developer Nanodegree.
I say project because everything that
follows here is completely optional.
What we're doing is trying to
give you the opportunity to start
thinking about your
final portfolio project
where you'll build an app of your own
creation completely from the ground up.
Now you might be thinking, hey,
I'm totally not ready for that.
I just got here.
I just did a course in Xcode and
I don't know what I might want to build.
And that's totally fine.
All of the content will
be repeated in the final
course which shows you how to
build an app from scratch.
But if you want to get started now,
we'll give you some tips and
tricks on how to brainstorm
an awesome idea.